[Music]
alright Gilmore Girls listen up the
highly anticipated Netflix revival is
officially out and we have some major
stars hollow secrets to discuss but if
you have not watched yet or do not want
to be spoiled about the major plot
points or those last four words leave
now I'm serious because we're about to
spill it all in 3 the Gilmore Girls
revival ended on a major cliffhanger
revealing that Rory is pregnant but we
didn't get to see any reactions to the
news from our Stars Hollow favorite so
et caught up with the cast to find out
how their characters would react to the
brand-new baby news if you think
Lorelei's reaction is we don't get to
see it on screen you know mix I mean I
don't I don't know of the entirety of
the circumstances but I think it's a
it's a thing I think but you know I
never know that's the truth Amy what Amy
writes and how I see the character were
often at I don't say they were at odds
but I was always surprised I'm like I
wouldn't think in a different way so I
don't know I can imagine how Christopher
react would react but I who knows how
Amy would write him how do you think
Luke's gonna react to that I don't I
don't think there was a gun in his car
at all and I don't think that he should
have been pulled over in the first place
it's ridiculous
whole thing's ridiculous it was it was
just a banana peel he slipped the gun
went off and what could it's Taylor
Sparks
well the Emily we know by the end of the
fourth episode probably be pretty cool
[Music]
you